Hello students, Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
This is the
Pharmacology of General
Anesthetics, the
second part. We're
going to be talking
about effects and
toxicities of the
inhaled anesthetics,
finishing up this
class of drugs.
And then we
will move into
the intravenous
anesthetics
and mention
adjuncts that are
used in anesthesia
technology.
Okay, effects.
I'm going to spend
quite a bit of
time talking
about the effects.
Cardiovascular,
so what are we thinking
about here? I know
you haven't had the
cardiovascular system,
but we're going to
just keep it simple.
We're talking about
the blood vessels,
and we know blood
vessels will constrict,
vasoconstriction, we
know blood vessels
will dilate vasodilation.
Vasoconstriction
increases blood pressure,
vasodilation decreases
blood pressure.
We also know that the
strength or the force
of myocardial contraction
is what pushes
the blood out of the
ventricles and into,
one, the pulmonary
circulation and to
the aorta. So we're
going to be talking
about cardiac output.
Cardiac output is the
amount of blood that
the heart pushes out
in a specific amount
of time per minute.
So that's cardiac
output. When the cardiac
output is reduced,
that's going to cause
a lower blood pressure.
When the cardiac
output increases,
that's going to cause
a higher blood pressure
because there's
more blood to push
against the vessels,
and therefore the
blood pressure goes up.
Now we need to talk
about the baroreflex
again. Baroreflex
senses the pressure
of the blood within
the vasculature,
mean arterial pressure.
When the mean arterial
pressure goes up,
the baroreflex is to
activate the parasympathetic
nervous system to
reduce the heart
rate. When the baroreflex
senses low blood
pressure, then the
sympathetic nervous system
becomes disinhibited,
and that will
increase the heart rate,
even causing tachycardia,
and constrict the
blood vessels, the
vasculature, to bring
up the blood pressure.
So cardiac output increases
and the vasculature
vasoconstricts
and both together
increase blood pressure.
So that's the baroreflex
that we're going to
be talking about.
So how do these
inhaled anesthetics
affect the various
organ systems? Well,
we see that they're
depressant on the
nervous system and
they're basically
depressant on the
other systems. However,
they have differences
among them.
On this chart,
I'm only talking
about isoflurane,
desflurane,
sevoflurane, and
nitrous oxide because
they're the ones
that are used.
We'll talk more about
the cardiovascular
in which I include
halothane again
because it could
appear on a board exam.
Basically, the
inhaled anesthetics,
the volatile
anesthetics, decrease
the blood pressure
with little
or no effect on
the cardiac output.
I'm talking about
these three.
And they depress
the baroreflex.
And I've indicated
to what degree.
Now, one other
thing happens.
Desflurane
actually causes
sympathetic stimulation.
I'll talk more about
that on the next slide.
Nitrous oxide
has negligible
effects on the
cardiovasculature,
mainly because
of net effects.
This is the
takeaway, though.
So hemodynamic
stability, think about if
it has low effects on
the cardiovascular,
the cardiovascular
system,
like nitrous oxide, then
there's hemodynamic
stability.
Respiratory, well,
respiratory
depression mainly.
Decreased tidal
volume, so that's
how much is being
breathed in,
and minute ventilation,
over minutes.
Decreased ventilatory
response to
carbon dioxide,
so when carbon dioxide
levels in the
blood go up,
the way we reduce those
is to blow them off.
So normally when
carbon dioxide
blood levels go
up, we breathe
faster, we breathe deeper
to blow off that
carbon dioxide.
Well, that
response has been
depressed by
the anesthetics.
So the respiratory
center is less sensitive
to noticing elevations
in carbon dioxide.
A good thing is
that they cause
bronchodilation,
especially sevoflurane.
That said, the drugs
that are pungent,
even though they
cause bronchodilation,
vasodilation can
cause coughing,
breath holding,
laryngospasm of
the larynx, and
bronchospasm because
that's the reflex
response to this
airway irritation.
Cevoflurine
doesn't cause that.
Cerebral effects, well,
cerebral depression.
The vasodilation
is going to
increase how much
blood is flowing
through the cerebral
vasculature.
So there's going to be
more blood
flowing through.
And more blood flowing
through means the
pressure inside the
cranium, which doesn't
expand with that
increased pressure,
is going to be higher.
And as these
are depressants,
CNS depressants,
the cerebral
metabolic rate
is gonna go down.
Sevolflurane we know
causes bronchodilation,
but it also decreases
the cerebral
blood flow and
the intracranial
pressure to a
lesser extent.
Nitrous oxide increases
all of these things.
Neuromuscular.
Well, these
volatile anesthetics
are skeletal
muscle relaxants,
which is a good
thing for surgery.
However, by giving
a neuromuscular
blocker, then
we don't need as
much depth of
anesthesia to produce
that skeletal
muscle relaxation,
which is a good
thing because we
know the deeper
the anesthesia,
the greater the risk
of moving into that
stage 4 and shutting
down the organ systems.
These drugs have a really
narrow therapeutic
window.
Nitrous oxide
does not relax
skeletal muscle,
or a smooth muscle.
And speaking of
smooth muscle,
the volatile
anesthetics also relax
smooth muscle, so
we're thinking about
the vasodilation,
the bronchodilation,
we're thinking
about uterine
smooth muscle relaxation,
and when does this
matter in pregnancy?
At times of labor
and delivery,
uterine smooth muscle
relaxation is
not desirable.
Decrease renal blood
flow, and that in
turn is going to
decrease the glomerular
filtration rate and
decrease urine output.
So, decreasing the whole
renal, the
kidney process.
Decreasing hepatic
blood flow also.
And here I've
got the hepatic
metabolism numbers again.
Don't have to memorize
these numbers.
Just take the concept.
Alright, let's
talk further about
these hemodynamic
effects. depression
of cardiac
contractility will
decrease the mean
arterial pressure.
Okay, why?
Depressing cardiac
contractility means
reducing the force
of contraction,
which means less
volume of blood is
going to be pushed
out of the heart
in a given amount
of time, which
means a decreased
cardiac output.
Alright, how are
these different drugs?
What's the differences
between these drugs?
Halothane and influrane,
more myocardial
depression.
In other words,
more depression
of this cardiac
contractility.
So that's going to
decrease the cardiac
output. But compared
to others, there's less
vasodilation, so that's
not going to change
the systemic vascular
resistance that much.
Looking at isoflurane,
desflurane, and
sevoflurane,
it causes vasodilation,
which is going
to decrease the blood
pressure, decrease
the systemic
vascular resistance,
which decreases
blood pressure.
But there's very
little change in the
cardiac output, Which
means that these three
drugs preserve cardiac
output and between
preserving cardiac output
and the vasodilation,
which decreases
the pressure that
the ventricles have
to push against and
decreases the preload,
which decreases the
amount of drug coming
back into the heart.
These are considered
preferable effects
compared to halothane
and influrane.
Why?
Isoflurane, desflurane,
and seboflurane
have minimal
myocardial depressant
effects. That's this
part, preserved cardiac
output, and
favorable hemodynamic
profiles and may be
suitable for patients
who have impaired
myocardial function.
And what does that
mean, myocardial
function? That
is the strength
of contraction of
the myocardium.
Now desflurane has
another little feature
here that I briefly
referred to earlier.
It causes a transient
sympathetic stimulation
because it releases
catecholamines.
Well, sympathetic
stimulation, we're
talking about
catecholamines, correct?
It's the
catecholamines that
produce the
adrenergic effects.
So, what's
going to happen?
Heart rate's going
up, tachycardia,
blood pressure's
going up.
These are transient,
that means they last
for a matter of minutes,
several minutes.
Especially when
the high doses are
used or the dose has
been increased by
ventilation by the
anesthesiologist.
Tachycardia can
persist. Okay, usually
that's not going to
be much of a problem.
But if a person
has coronary
artery disease,
which is plaques,
angina,
meaning the coronary
arteries tend to be
occluded and don't
deliver as much
oxygen as in the non
-diseased coronary
arteries, that can
lead to a heart attack,
an ischemic episode
and a heart attack.
So that's a word
of caution with the
desflurane because
of that sympathetic
stimulation. Even
though it only
lasts probably less
than 10 minutes,
it can still be a
problem in people
with coronary
artery disease.
All right, emergence.
So patients, the
drug has been
discontinued and
the patient will now
be emerging from
the anesthetic,
all of these
volatile anesthetics
can cause nausea and
vomiting. It just is.
And nitrous oxide
seems to have
the highest
incidence of it.
They cause nausea
and vomiting because,
after all, they're
going everywhere
and they're basically
a poison. The
body doesn't
recognize these drugs,
recognizes them as
intruders, as poison.
So that's going to
trigger the chemoreceptor
trigger zone and
vomiting center.
Nausea and vomiting.
Well, this can
be managed,
fortunately, with
antiemetics, and I've
listed some here.
You don't have to
memorize those. Just
remember drugs that
prevent nausea and
vomiting. avoiding,
avoid nitrous oxide,
use propofol, now
this is an intravenous
that happens to
have anti-emetic
properties, we'll be
talking about this one.
And don't use
opioids, use something
else, Ketorolac
is an NSAID,
non-steroidal anti
-inflammatory drug.
This is the main
one, but there are
different strategies
as you can see.
So a patient's blood
pressure and heart rate
are going to go up.
They're coming out of
this traumatic episode
they've been through,
even though they've
been anesthetized,
and they're also going
to be likely in pain,
and that's going
to increase
hypertension
and tachycardia.
And it just so happens
that there is post
-anesthesia shivering.
The ORs tend to be
cold, and the body
cavity has been opened,
and possibly
the IV fluids
that are being
used are cold,
and so that
core temperature
goes down, and
patients shiver.
And emergence
excitement, tachycardia,
restlessness, crying,
moaning, thrashing.
And the neurologic
signs have also
been temporarily
altered, so we can see
differences in our
neurologic signs.
Okay, toxicity.
This is just a
little chart to
help you see
which toxicities
the individual
drugs will show.
Malignant hyperthermia,
the takeaway here
is the halogenated
drugs, not nitrous oxide.
They all have a very
narrow therapeutic
window. This is low
therapeutic index.
Hepatotoxicity,
this is the reason
I've included
halothane here.
I've seen this on
board exams, I've
seen this on board
review questions,
and it's an
important concept.
Sevolflurane produces
this product here
that's been given
the name compound A,
which has been
theorized to cause
nephrotoxicity. It
hasn't been seen in
humans, but it has
been seen in animals.
And n-flurane, as
far as I'm concerned,
you don't have to
look at that one.
Now, B12 deficiency.
Here we have
nitrous oxide, vitamin
B12, and anemia.
Environmental toxicity.
Every single one of them.
These drugs, these
inhaled anesthetics,
are vented into the
outside environment.
Now, I have descriptions
here, the other
was just a chart to
help you organize them.
The acute toxicities,
because of the
narrow therapeutic
range, organ damage is
low when it's used by
trained people, but
it can be high if
it's used by people
who are not qualified
to use these drugs.
Malignant hyperthermia,
this is related
to people who have
genetic disorders of
skeletal muscle, which
may not be obvious.
They can develop the
rigidity, hyperthermia,
tachycardia,
hypercapnia, that's
elevated carbon
dioxide levels,
elevated potassium
levels, and metabolic
acidosis. We talked
about it with
succinylcholine.
It also happens with
the halogenated,
which are the
volatile anesthetics.
Nitrous oxide
does not cause it.
We talked about
nephrotoxicity before.
Hepatotoxicity,
hepatic dysfunction
following surgery and
general anesthesia is
most likely caused
by what the patient
is going through
rather than the drug.
I'll talk about halothane
hepatitis at
a later slide.
Neurotoxicity.
There is this concern
of neurotoxicity
in infants and
young children.
Studies are ongoing.
So far, it's just
not clear what the
neurotoxic effects
are in children.
Let's talk about
carbon monoxide
poisoning.
Carbon monoxide,
think about the
breathing circuit.
Well, inside that
breathing circuit is
a product that will
remove carbon dioxide
from the breathing
circuit so that
the patient can
reuse the air in that
breathing circuit.
Well, if that product
is dried out, the
halogenated anesthetics
can form carbon
monoxide, which
will then be breathed
in by the patient.
Really important to
change that carbon
dioxide absorber so
that there's the fresh
absorber in there.
It's not dried out.
And here's the
potential for
carbon monoxide
formation.
Desflurane is the
worst offender,
isoflurane, and
semoflurane much
less so, but it
can still cause it.
Carcogenicity.
Well, these drugs don't
appear to cause cancer.
Pregnancy.
Pregnant patients are
sometimes going to
have to have surgery,
and the surgery may
require the use of an
inhaled anesthetic.
There appears to be
an increased incidence
in loss of the fetus
with these drugs,
but the reason for
it is not clear.
And then I mentioned
the environment before.
These drugs are
super, super,
super potent
greenhouse gases.
Nitrous oxide
has some other
features to be aware of.
So the ones that we saw
before, all
those features.
Now, it can cause
body space volume
expansion. You
need to understand
the mechanisms
of these effects.
So nitrous oxide, N2O,
is 35 times
approximately more
soluble in blood
than nitrogen, N2.
Therefore, nitrous
oxide diffuses
into cavities faster
than nitrogen can
diffuse out. So
we're talking about
air-filled cavities
at this point.
So because there's
both nitrous oxide
and nitrogen
in there, that
increases the volume
inside the cavity,
and so the
cavity expands.
However, when the walls
of the cavity are rigid,
such as in the eye, such
as in the middle ear,
the pressure will rise
instead of the volume.
Cautions, these
are the cautions.
So people who have
a pneumothorax,
people with
intracranial error,
middle ear surgery,
bowel obstruction.
Nitrous oxide
should be avoided in
these patients
because of this
body space volume
expansion effect.
And just an FYI,
the nitrous oxide
can also diffuse
into the tracheal
tube cuff and
that can increase
the pressure
against the trachea.
Vitamin B12.
Nitrous oxide interferes
with vitamin
B12 functions.
Vitamin B12 is
essential for
the functions
of methionine.
When vitamin B12
is deficient, that
can cause anemia.
It's called vitamin
B12 megaloblastic
anemia and megaloblastic
anemia due to vitamin
B12 deficiency
can cause peripheral
neuropathy.
So nitrous oxide
should not be used for
chronic pain relief
because the patient
will be exposed to
this nitrous oxide
repeatedly and and
over time. And that
will eventually
reduce the stores of
B12 and lead to
megaloblastic anemia.
The drug should
also be avoided
in patients who
already have B12
deficiency,
folate deficiency,
methionine synthesis, or
metabolism deficiency.
Diffusion hypoxia
now. So when
nitrous oxide
is discontinued,
the nitrous oxide
naturally is
going to diffuse out
of the blood back
into the lungs
via the alveoli.
The nitrous
oxide will then
dilute the oxygen
in the alveoli.
So what do we do?
Administer oxygen.
And this is
done for a few
minutes before
the nitrous oxide
is discontinued
and afterwards.
Now there's something
called a second
gas effect.
When we remember
that nitrous
oxide is quite
insoluble in blood,
therefore it is taken up
rapidly from the LVLI.
It moves into the blood
and quickly approaches
equilibrium.
Well, contraction
of the alveolar
volume that as the
nitrous oxide leaves
concentrates the
co-administered
inhaled drug that's
left in the alveoli.
So now we have
more concentration,
higher concentration,
and that's going
to speed induction.
This is something
that's always brought
up. Remember,
nitrous oxide isn't
used alone. It's used
with other things.
It produces a nice,
smooth induction.
But it's
probably actually
insignificant in
clinical practice.
It's still something
that you, it's
a concept you
need to remember.
All right now we're on to
halothene hepatitis.
This is rare.
It still can
occur. Halothene
is still used
in some areas of
the world. It's
quite cheap.
It is metabolized by
CYP2E1 and it forms
reactive intermediate
which is unstable
and I've indicated
right here and it can
form something called
neoantigen, so it
binds to liver proteins
and it will draw
the immune system,
it's immunogenic, it
will draw the immune
system to attack it.
And the immune system
attack will cause
inflammation and liver
cell damage. So we
have direct toxicity
by this unstable
intermediate, and we
have this immune attack.
There are certain
risk factors for this.
For example, previous
exposure to halothane.
It seems to be
higher incidence in
the obese female.
That doesn't mean that
nobody else will
develop this, but that's
the way the population
incidence goes.
And the CO2
absorber, I've
given you a picture here
of the product and
the CO2 absorber
within the
breathing circuit.
These are highly
basic, although
the newer ones
are less so.
When the CO2
absorber is dried out
and the anesthetic,
the halogenated
anesthetic passes
through it, this is
when carbon monoxide
can be formed.
That's the basic idea,
that's the concept.
And the prevention, make
sure that it's fresh.
Desflurane greater
than n-flurane,
which there's,
I mean, they all
still produce
carbon monoxide.
Desflurane seems to be
the worst
culprit, though.
Okay, here's xenon.
You do not have to
memorize this. This
is an example of what
the ideal gas anesthetic
would look like.
Highly insoluble,
inert at room
temperature and
standard pressure,
doesn't catch on fire.
Xenon happens to be
a non-competitive
antagonist of the NMDA
receptor and other
effects. Has minimal
side effects, how good is
that? No cardiovascular
effects, respiratory
depression, renal
or hepatic toxicity,
not metabolized,
environmentally safe,
but it is super
expensive because it's
obtained by extracting
it from air.
And it's not
approved in the
U.S. It is
approved elsewhere.
Alright, check
your knowledge.
What is the acronym
that MAC stands for?
Minimum alveolar
concentration.
How does it
define potency?
One MAC is the
concentration of
inhaled gas in the
alveoli that prevents
movement in 50
% of patients in
response to a
standardized stimulus
at standard temperature
and ambient pressure.
MAC reflects the
brain partial
pressure and
allows comparisons
of potency
between agents.
So how is it
used in dosing?
Dosing is guided
by MAC and
MAC values are additive.
Which ones are the potent
volatile anesthetics?
Isoflurane, desflurane,
and sevoflurane
are the ones that
are in common use.
And why is nitrous oxide
referred to as a
weak anesthetic.
It has low potency.
Even 100% nitrous
oxide does not
achieve one MAC.
Therefore, it's
combined with a potent
volatile anesthetic.
That's the typical use.
Why may isoflurane,
desflurane, and
suboflurane be
suitable for patients
with impaired
myocardial function?
because they cause
vasodilation, which
lowers systemic vascular
resistance and blood
pressure with minimal
change to cardiac
output, which preserves
cardiac output.
And of course, always
we have to be monitoring
patients throughout
anesthesia care.
And although
desflurane causes
vasodilation with minimal
effect on force
of contraction,
myocardial
depressant effects.
Its transient
sympathomimetic properties
cause tachycardia
and hypertension,
especially at high dose,
and that can induce
cardiac ischemia
and heart attack in
patients with coronary
artery disease.
Which inhaled anesthetics
are associated
with malignant
hyperthermia in
patients with
genetic disorder and
skeletal muscle
calcium regulation.
The halogenated ones,
but not nitrous oxide.
And this is
just a matching.
I invite you to
do this on your
own. The answers
to all of
these questions
are at the end.
I hope you try it
on your own first.
And intravenous
anesthetics. We'll be
able to go through
these pretty quickly.
These are basic
concepts, basic
pharmacokinetic concepts
that you are familiar
with because these
drugs are administered
intravenously in
milligram doses.
So let's take a look
at their features.
Redistribution is
an important concept
with highly
lipophilic drugs. So a
single bolus
dose, one dose, is
administered and it
will go go to the
highly-perfused
tissues first, the CNS,
and other highly-perfused
organs. See this
two-way arrow?
Then, as the circulation
goes around again,
makes the circuit,
it will go through
the venous system,
the arterial system,
venous system,
drop off some drug
to the various
compartments, muscle
and fat and circle back
to the brain at
lower concentrations
and now the drug
will move out of the
brain back into the
circulation where
it again goes into
the other tissues.
Decreasing the amount
of drug in the brain
tissue. As the drug
concentration in
blood decreases, the
anesthetic begins to
redistribute out of
the CNS to the less
-perfused tissues,
diminishing the effect. The
patient emerges from
anesthesia. So the
patient emerges because
the concentration
of drug in the brain
tissue is low, even
though the drug is
still in the body. But
eventually, the drug
will be eliminated.
Now context
-sensitive halftime
is the half-life related,
the plasma half
-life, related
to the duration
of infusion.
So halftime, you're
familiar with that
concept. Time
required for the
concentration of drug
to decrease by 50%
after stopping a
continuous infusion.
We're talking
about not one bolus
dose now, but a
continuous infusion.
And that amount of
time is going to depend
on how long that drug
has been infused.
So we know the IV
anesthetic initially
distributes to the
well-perfused tissue,
and the drug
redistributes to the
less-perfused tissue.
So the longer the
infusion, the more
drug accumulates
in the muscle and
fat compartments.
So after the infusion
is stopped, the
drug will leave the
blood by the usual
elimination method,
metabolism and
excretion, and that
will mobilize the
drug to move out
of the tissue
compartments and back
into the bloodstream.
drug redistributes
from peripheral
compartments back
into the bloodstream.
For drugs that have been
infused for a
long duration,
the context-sensitive
half-time, so the
amount of time to
decrease by 50% out of the
blood, can be significantly
longer than we
would see with that
same drug in a short
infusion. because of the
extensive accumulation
in the fat and
muscle compartments.
Why do we care?
Context-sensitive
halftime helps predict
how long it will take
the patient to recover
after the infusion
is stopped.
And this chart
will show the
differences in
context-sensitive
halftimes between
the various drugs.
Diazepam, thiopental,
which isn't used
anymore, have these really
long context-sensitive
half times. They're
highly lipophilic,
and they cling to the
peripheral tissues.
Propofol, litomidate,
ketamine, they're
down here on the
bottom, so their
recovery tends to
be faster with them.
Looking at the
mechanisms and the
uses, propofol,
atomidate, and
ketamine, which I'm
focusing on here.
Ketamine is a non
-competitive NMDA receptor
antagonist. The others
are GABA-A receptor
positive allosteric
modulators, like
the benzodiazepines,
like the barbiturates.
Rapid anesthesia
induction, rapid sequence
intubation,
total intravenous
anesthesia, especially
propofol, sedative,
hypnotic, and ICU,
especially propofol,
monitored anesthesia care
sedation,
especially propofol.
Propofol is a really
useful intravenous
anesthetic. It has many
favorable qualities.
And here they
are. Propofol
causes bronchodilation,
decreases the cerebral
metabolic rate
of oxygen consumption,
which is measurable.
The cerebral blood flow,
the intracranial
pressure, it is
antiemetic and
antipyretic, prevents
itching, and
anticonvulsant properties.
And here are some
problems with it. These
are pretty common we
see with anesthetics,
hypotension,
respiratory depression.
Propofol infusion
syndrome, I've indicated
down here, you should
be familiar with this.
It is rare, but the
anesthesiologist
really has to be alert to
looking for signs
and symptoms.
It's a painful
injection, It's usually
given with an opioid
anyway for anesthesia.
This is an
interesting feature
of the actual
formulation.
It comes in a four ounce
bottle, it's not
a big amount.
So in certain
anesthesia, in
certain surgical
procedures,
a large number of
these bottles is going
to be necessary
because in order to
emulsify this propofol
it's in an egg phosphate
and soybean oil
vehicle which is a
lovely bacterial medium
and as a result there
is a potent microbial
sorry a high
microbial risk and
also with this egg and
soybean stuff, their
potential allergens.
So once the bottle
is spiked for the IV
infusion, it has to
be used right away.
Etomidate hemodynamic
stability,
so there are no
changes in blood
pressure. That's a
big takeaway. Also,
it's really,
really fast acting.
And it has anti-convulsant
properties. Now,
this has some
interesting side effects.
Painful, I mean,
these you can expect.
Has no analgesic effects.
It causes myoclonus. This
is myoclonus, so clonus.
So this involuntary
muscle movements.
And it's not
related to seizures.
Myoclonus can
sometimes be related
to seizures,
but this is not.
And it inhibits
this enzyme called
11-beta-hydroxylase,
which is necessary
for the synthesis
of cortisol.
So it's going to
cause this adrenal
suppression for the
short amount of time
that the atomidate
is in the body,
which means
atomidate should not
be used for long
infusions, such as
would be sedation
of the mechanically
ventilated patient
in the ICU.
So this is some
unique feature
that should
be remembered.
And this one, this
is not serious, but
it is a unique feature,
this myoclonus.
Now ketamine has
profound analgesic
properties. This is
a non-competitive
NMDA receptor inhibitor
like nitrous oxide,
and both of them
have these great
analgesic properties,
pain inhibition.
Ketamine causes
bronchodilation,
also a nice feature.
Sympathetic stimulation
I have on both sides.
So sympathetic stimulation
can be beneficial
in people who have
hemodynamic instability
but it can be harmful
in patients who have
hypertension or
coronary artery disease.
So sympathetic
stimulation is
something to remember
here too too.
And it can be given
IM if necessary.
This is also
a key feature.
All of these are
key features, but
this is a unique
feature. It can
cause hallucinations
and delirium,
dissociative experiences,
terrible nightmares,
and nausea and vomiting
upon withdrawal
of of the drug, and
all of these are
drugs you need to
know for this block.
Dexmedetomidine I have
in here because it's
an alpha-2 agonist,
and its features are
like Clonidine, which
was in block one,
which is why it
has a star on it.
You've already
learned about it.
And I've defined
here monitored
anesthesia care.
These drugs are often
used in monitored
anesthesia care,
which is IV drugs,
and the patient usually
has no endotracheal
intubation. And so
the anesthesiologist
is just monitoring
the level of sedation.
I've talked about
them here. I'm
not going to go
into details.
You can see them
for yourself.
Benzodiazepines we
talked about in seizures.
You'll see them again
in sedative hypnotics.
Propofol we talked about.
Ketamine we talked about.
Dexmedetomidine
is this alpha-2
-adrenergic agonist,
which is like
clonidine. has the
same effects as
clonidine, it is
more sedating,
got good anxiolytic
properties,
it has some
analgesic properties.
So these are important
features of
dexmedetomidine.
Slower onset
of sedation, so
they're not great
for the immediate
sedation, or
nearly immediate.
Radycardia
hypotension dry
mouth, same as clonidine.
So this is
features of the
alpha 2 receptor agonism,
central,
so inhibition of central
sympathetic actions.
Opioids is part of
this block, lidocaine
is part of this
block. So you can,
these are just
brief summaries of
the effects you'll
learn more, that
you have learned
or will learn more
about each individual
group of drugs.
And the summary, I'm
not going through this
all with you. I had
this in the beginning.
Advantages and
disadvantages.
Nitrous oxide.
All of the various
IV agents. and the
answers to the questions
so thank you very
much this had to be a
long video because there
is so much to tell
you about good luck